being Christian like these I I just T
it's not that I believe every story that
I hear but I'm open to the possibility
that this this stuff exists and what
you're describing is right out of a
medieval Legend you know what you're
describing is right out of a classic
horror movie on this stuff the low
sounds have a have a spiritual analog
the The Cutting and the blood is
physical but then it has a metaphysical
implication to it and I I see all of
that so so
then what are the nuts and bolts of it
like you you tell me that the witches
don't have green skin they don't
necessarily have big warty scaly noses
they don't necessarily fly around on
broomsticks I don't know maybe they do
so what is the what is the day
today look like for a witch what's the
fact from fiction I can't tell you from
my experience what we were doing we
wouldn't running running around in in BR
sticks or doing those type of things but
for us it was it was normal waking up
every every day set up some candles and
cleanses for the house doing some also
cleansing on our on on ourselves
preparing for for the day um and just
taking with us all the protections the
crystals these type of things reading
tarot cards that's kind of like our day
to-day look like um and then when we
were outside as I said we never said to
anyone like we are witches we are doing
this we would just walk around and be
normal people you know the the Bible is
takes a pretty harsh line against
witchcraft Thou shalt not suffer a witch
to live you know that that sort of thing
um and I remember reading it at first
thinking well that's a pretty harsh line
against something that's not real why
why are they why is God so insistent
that people not do something which is
not possible to do and now I have a
little bit more of an open mind on that
I guess but but why is scripture
so harsh on witchcraft in particular you
know even more than certain other sins I
think it's because witchcraft
counterfeit what God has given us as a
spiritual people when I come out of
Witchcraft I started to realize that
there were so many
similarities that I was doing on that
side that when I became Christian I
realized like wow this is like the real
thing and this is the opposite one of
them was for example in the Bible we see
prophetic acts we see the anointing oil
we see in the Bible the salt with
Prophet Elijah did a prophet at we salt
in the water right and then you see that
which is you Sal for cleansing for
purification for curses for H cursing
people drying all all of those things
and then you also have the rainbow right
the rainbow the enemy counters fit
absolutely everything you have also the
blood as I was saying the blood is
powerful for covenants we have the blood
of Jesus so when I came out of that I
realized wow this is this witchcraft is
trying to kind of steal and counterfeit
what represents God so I believe that's
why God is so strict and so like don't
witchcraft don't go to medion don't do
necromancy why because between God's
kingdom and the occultism and Witchcraft
there is a really thin line that even
you as a Christian you can be stepping
in Without You realizing so that's why
we have to be careful and I believe
that's why God Is So drastic to like
don't do that because the enemy coping
is taking this that is God's kingdom is
taking it for his kingdom and I feel
like that's one of the reasons Pro
probably most of all the different
witchcraft FL flors you know it's like a
bag of Jolly Ranchers the green and the
purple and the red and the white U the
the most dangerous would seem to me to
be the the white witchcraft because it
seems the nicest so it seems the most
palatable and therefore but it's not
it's not good right it's not actually
benign no because all type of Witchcraft
is bad regardless of what you do you you
read tarot cards you go outside to speak
to Nat or do things in nature or you
think you're doing this for the universe
whatever you are doing is bad why
because it's counterfeit because we have
the Holy Spirit and then in here you
have another spirit that is guiding that
experience so actually the question that
we should ask is like okay who is
guiding your experience this is the real
thing if it's not the Holy Spirit then
is another Spirit then is witchcraft new
age do do witches go out into the woods
and worship the moon this is something
that comes up in really that's that
really happen do happen especially
during Halloween there is like a certain
connection with the moon there is
certain connection with stars with the
blue moon with the red moon with all of
those things that they believe that it
opens up in the spiritual realm so
something important to understand is
that there are principles for the
spiritual realm as I was saying with the
with the blood with the sacrifices with
the it might look like oh this is
ancient this is weird coming from a book
but this is a spiritual principles and
this happens and this is happening today
this is the Satanist they are doing it
because they understand that that there
is something so they they go out they do
rituals when there's full moon they do
rituals when there's like no even ritual
just go outside and may maybe like
dancing around because they believe and
this is why I believe as Christians we
need to step into the power and the
fullness that the Lord is giving us not
just just not just going to church and
just clapping hands but there's more
than that the Lord has given us the
authority and the power through Jesus
Christ to take over Nations to impact
the Earth so why are we believing like
oh this is just coming from a book when
in reality wait a minute this has been
given to us what we are doing is kind of
like blocking what the Lord has given
and just thinking this is not real this
this doesn't exist okay you live your
life and I will continue to God's
working here that's a really important
point because in modern Christian
circles Protestant and to some degree
Catholic too you'll see a kind of
political quietism creep in meaning this
notion that the church should not be
involved in public life we just we have
our freedom of worship in our own houses
of worship sometimes when they're not
shutting them down or burning them down
based on blood liel like they did up in
Canada uh but we shouldn't interfere
with uh public policy or anything like
that I think
well if it's true if if all this stuff
is true then it should be true in public
just like it's true in private and if
it's not true then what are we doing
right you know the the earlier
conception of religion was that of
course it's a public thing the the
ancient pagans believed that religion
was a public matter of course major the
temple to Athena was not only a you know
religious place but also a kind of
Monument to the glories of Athens of of
of course the sports festivals were were
religious festivals always and then at
the height of Western
Christendom and Eastern Christendom I
guess for that matter you had not a a a
total uh overlap of the church and the
state but a fair bit of overlap at least
the two work together because every
state is going to worship something you
know everybody's got to serve somebody
so so how is that going to be informed
is that going to be informed by paganism
is that going to be informed by private
Intuition or is that going to be
informed by the church if you really
believe that Christ instituted a church
on Earth Earth and said you know go
forth make Apostles of all Nations well
he's talking about Nations isn't he
really important point we we do have
Limbs and minds and we live in time and
space and we can actually do things to
affect the world around us not just
exactly all right my rant is over I just
that was such a good point that you
brought up and and we we ignore that all
too much but the other people don't
ignore it that's my point this is why
when I come out of that I saw the church
and I'm like oh L uh you really want me
and I feel like a lot of people that
come out of the occultism right not just
me but a lot of people that I have talk
to that are trying to come out of that
they say something they say like oh I'm
trying to come out of that but I feel
like I'm losing my power you know why
because they see the church and the
church is asleeping and I'm like no no
no no listen you're not going to lose
your gift because the the gifts are are
the and the calling are irrevocable
that's something that the Lord has given
to you but the enem is grabbing your
gift for for his kingdom for his use but
this is the point that just because you
are a Christian it doesn't necessarily
mean that you have to be sitting in a
church it doesn't necessarily mean that
you have to be Qui not all the time at
least we have been given a mission we
have been given a voice we hav been
given the Holy Spirit to impact so we as
the church why are we going to allow
Darkness to advance if we have the power
and authority through Jesus Christ to
conquer and to take over
Nations right you know a phrase that's
fallen out of use is the notion of the
church militant you know there's the
church suffering there is the church
triumphant in heaven and then there's
the church militant that's us here you
know in time and space on Earth and a
priest friend of mine once said that
there are too many pacifists in the
church militant too many people just
passively letting things go by but of
course uh our enemies are not are not
doing that they're they're quite active